well it's a facility to help local
police officers prepare for the worst
that's right well today for the very
first time some of nevada's senators got
the tour of metro's reality-based
training center our very own victoria
saha was there
this tactical training facility has
everything law enforcement would need to
prepare for real life scenarios their
newest project will be making a
makeshift school here in their newest
building being prepared for any type of
critical incident is crucial when every
second matters at metro's newest reality
based training center senators catherine
cortez masto and jackie rosen secured 3
million dollars in federal funding to
help buy technology training equipment
and other resources following recent
details out of the texas school shooting
where police waited several minutes to
enter the classroom where the gunman
killed 19 students and two teachers
undersheriff christopher darcy says a
training facility like this helps his
team to respond immediately what we see
right in texas even a horrible massacre
that occurs at a school so now we can
look at that lessons learned to make
sure that we do better here right we
want to make sure that we're always in
the forefront of policing and tactics
that's what this facility will enable us
to do no matter how long an officer has
been with the department they are
required to go through routine training
so it continues to be muscle memory
those who assisted in friday's tour says
they are confident they have everything
they need in this facility to respond
immediately to a situation to help keep
our community safe whether you're living
in southern nevada or just visiting here
victoria zaha live local now